welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is
hisham azuz today i'm really excited to
be joined by dwayne cormell
who is the founder of realm recruit and
the legal
job coach dwayne has worked in the
recruitment industry for over a decade
but for the last five years he's been
focused on building realm recruit
who are a specialist within legal
markets
despite challenges during the last 12 to
18 months dwayne has
managed to come out the other side of
kovid having grown his business
in head count and also as a business
they're well on track to set new records
um and hopefully achieve their first
million pound year in
revenue dwayne welcome to the podcast
thank you so much for having me i'm
really excited
so where we always like to start is in
your opinion
what characteristics and traits do you
think make up a highly
successful recruitment consultant okay
so um you had me on 15 minutes with
recently and i
touched on this point then but we've got
to start off with communication skills
recruitment in my humble opinion is
about people
and your success or otherwise hinges
heavily
i think on your ability to form
relationships with them
and i think i shared this when we spoke
before but
there's a book by a lady called susan
scott called fierce conversations
and whilst i wouldn't necessarily
recommend everybody go out and read it
there's a really powerful
line that she uses in it and the line is
the conversation is the relationship
and i found that really mega profound
like it was almost like this light bulb
cha-ching moment yeah like any
relationship you have yes there's
non-verbal cues and all the rest of it
but more than anything else the quality
or otherwise of them hinges on the
relation the the relationships you have
sorry
the quality of otherwise of them hinges
on the conversations you have right
so you've got to have good communication
skills written
verbal that's that's just a nailed on
for me um
and i'm sure we'll it won't be long
before i mention this anyway but
in realm we use a tool called ima
identify modify adapt
and it's all about better understanding
the way
you communicate as an individual and the
way others communicate
and modifying and adapting your
communication accordingly to
better connect with people um and we've
seen
a lot of positives through putting
that's all in place so absolutely number
one good communication skills
the next thing i would say is empathy
again given that
we're dealing with people and that
humans by definition are imperfect and
can sometimes disappoint
you've got to have a degree of empathy
to really
put yourself in the shoes of the other
person to see it from their perspective
because otherwise you're going to get
worn down in my humble opinion
recruitment is necessarily full of
setbacks
i would also say that having good
organization
is a pretty fundamental need
so whether or not the business you work
in has got good systems and processes in
place or not
i think you need to be able to organize
yourself in such a way
that it's clear day-to-day what you're
going to be doing
it's clear how you're going to follow
those organize and follow those systems
and processes
because ultimately there's that old
adage about spinning plates right and
recruitment is just like that there's
lots of things going on simultaneously
and if you take your eye off one for too
long it crashes smashes and then yeah
that
necessarily comes through in your
performance and your billings
and i'll go for one more if that's okay
yeah that's fine
uh resilience yeah i'm trying
to be positive and not be negative
um and i've but i've said it already
recruitment comes with setbacks right
everybody that works in recruitment
knows that
and you've got to be resilient if you
expect to have anything like a
long lasting meaningful career in
recruitment
yeah for sure no thank you great great
points there so
let's let's just obviously we're going
to really focus on
sort of dwayne the business owner and
and the sort of realm journey but
let's just touch on it really quickly
because i think there's always sort of
interesting stories or things to be
learned from
sort of early days in recruitment
so from what from what i can see then
obviously
went to university to do law and then
you graduated
and then didn't become didn't work in
the profession but decided to recruit
lawyers instead
basically it wasn't quite as
strategically thought i was that if i'm
honest
um i mean does anybody in does anybody
deliberately set out to be a recruiter
no i don't think they do i think nine
nine times i think that's changing
i think yeah no i think i i'd like to
think it's changing because
i think there's a lot going for this
profession otherwise i won't be here 10
years later
but yeah and my point being
certainly when i went into recruitment
it wasn't a well thought out you know
long-term aspiration
frankly it was something i fell in fell
into and it was as simple as this
i wanted to be a barrister it cost
something like certainly it did at the
time 15 grand
to do a qualification after you've
already paid for your degree
degree yeah and you've got to pay 15
grand you've got to find money to also
live off in the meantime
and that doesn't even guarantee that
you're gonna get over the line
and i just thought well that's a bit of
a gamble and i backed my you know i'd
back myself at the time don't get me
wrong but i thought what would be good
is if i went and earned a bit of money
first
to give me a bit of a safety net and the
company that
that i ultimately worked for they
basically hired me for two reasons
one because i had a law degree and they
recruited lawyers
and two the patch that they wanted
somebody to recruit into
was in and around birmingham and 10 11
years ago
my brummie accent being from birmingham
was a lot thicker
so they were like
yeah yeah fair enough so how how would
you describe your first gen recruitment
then
because it's typically a difficult year
for a lot of people
miserable really honestly miserable uh
why is it so miserable
again i'm conscious i don't want to come
on here and be all neggy because as i've
told you before my non-negotiable with
myself day-to-day is to be a positive
person but
i guess i can we can we can put a
positive spin on it and sort of talk
about what you learn but let's i think
and people want to know that it's not
all rosy and it's all positive right so
why was it miserable it was miserable
because i went into it for the wrong
reason to start off with
i thought i thought oh it'll be a job
that i'll earn a bit of money and be
easy and straightforward and it's not
that recruitment is not easy and it's
not straightforward
as i've already said you need resilience
because there are a lot of setbacks
so coupled me going into it naively
coupled with the fact that i don't think
i necessarily got the training guidance
and support that somebody
so naive and young and
lacking in experience needed those
things compounded to me not really
performing very well
and when you're not performing very well
in recruitment
um in most companies at least i don't
think that's a very
enjoyable experience nice grim and um
i think on top of that and this is
nobody's fault
just the way it was most people within
that business were a good 10 years older
than me
so yeah just on a human level there was
nobody there i could really
kind of connect with all connect with
and bounce with day to day
so yeah it was pretty miserable and
again you know if we're gonna if we are
gonna spin the positive of it because
there is a positive actually
it's that that made me lose confidence
and made me think
i've really achieved nothing in this
year i've got no money saved to go and
do this barrister thing
so i've got to keep going and
the more i stuck at it the more i got
into it
i suppose the more i did start to see
the upsides of recruitment
yeah and i guess if i'd had a decent
first year
and managed to put some money away i
would have been like great i've achieved
what i need to achieve
and i would have disappeared off and
done the barrister gig and i wouldn't be
there today
yeah that's a good point so i guess for
people listening then that might be
going through that early period what
would what would you say to them
because obviously sometimes it can be
really hard to see the light at the end
of the tunnel
when you're working through that
um i think the hard bit is i think
what i would say to them would depend on
why they're feeling like that and
when you're in that situation yourself
at that time you may not necessarily
know
so for example you may feel that way
because you're not in the right company
because you're not aligned with what
this company is about because you're not
getting the
training support that you need but that
might not be that clear to you
but if if that were the situation i
would say think twice about whether
you're in the right place and maybe look
around
because there are lots of really good
recruitment businesses out there
what a good just on that sorry to button
what are those questions
what are good questions these people can
ask themselves i'm sure these are types
of questions you get your people to ask
themselves that could maybe discover or
enough
those things i suppose i'd start off
with a fairly simple one do i feel like
i know how to do this job
good question um because actually if i'd
said that to myself
six months in um let me rephrase it do i
know how to do this job
to the point where i feel capable of
hitting that billing target that i've
got
if i'd asked myself that six to 12
months in the answer would have been no
yeah um and i think if the answer is no
then i'm you're not necessarily in the
wrong place you know
the answer isn't always leave the grass
isn't always greener but certainly you
need to try and address that
that issue and it might be going to your
line manager your director asking for
more support training or whatever
or you know ultimately maybe it might be
moving elsewhere where you're going to
get that
yeah nice so i guess just on this then
just uh one or two more things on the
sort of early days
what um what so if you could go back and
communicate to dwayne then as you were
going into recruitment because you
wanted to save some money to become a
barrister
what would you know what you know now
what would you say to him
well because of that age gap right
and because of it being my first real
experience of being in an office setting
i i suppose i felt that i had to behave
in a certain way that wasn't natural to
me
and i had to talk in a way that wasn't
natural to me either
and i don't think that helped so the
first thing i'd say is be authentic
you know who own who you are um
certainly the more that the more that
i've
done that in my career the more i feel
that
i've benefited that i've that i've felt
mentally in a better place
i feel that there's been success around
me
so that that would be one thing that i
would say
um i i was really fixated
and just been good at recruitment in the
early days without really knowing
what that meant what i thought it meant
was
being good at putting in
the hours being good at getting the
numbers and maybe that's part of it
but actually if what if what you're
doing
is making you know 50 bd calls a day and
all those bd calls are
hi have you got any jobs well you need
an above picking up the phone you may as
well have just sat there
thinking about doing something else but
being truthful that's the sort of thing
that i used to do
i didn't know otherwise um so
with hindsight i would advise myself now
um the person i am now i'd advise me
back then don't just make it about
recruitment make make it about
relationships add value talk to people
in a normal meaningful way
and um don't you know don't try as hard
you know focus on doing less and doing
that less better
yeah i love that so and then just the
final point
just because i think by the time we
release this it will be and
we're doing a few things around just
focused on
sort of graduates obviously graduating
uh this year or
just people going into the workplace for
the first time obviously i've seen
obviously you have quite obviously you
have a young
fairly young team um
i guess just just a quick point it might
be related to what you just said but
like
what do you play do you place grads into
law
firms or is that not something no from
time to time
from time to time we do um yeah not all
that often but yeah
occasionally i guess the question just
was i was just interested would be like
obviously you haven't been a grad
yourself
or like entering the workplace for the
first time any advice for people that
might be listening to this that could be
find themselves entering the workplace
for the first time particularly
recruitment
for me i from the the messages that i
get
on a weekly basis so i really do feel
like recruitment will become a career
choice
um and and i think hopefully part of
this podcast
what it should be achieving because it's
one of our goals is like actually
painting a real picture of what to
expect so there's less surprises
um and there's a real picture going into
it rather than just being sold the
the typical recruitment dream so i guess
anyone just final point on this is like
anyone listening to this that
might be graduating this year or
entering the workplace for the first
time which you can obviously relate to
as well like what would your advice be
to them
i don't know whether or not this is what
you're looking for but
what comes to mind is that recruitment
is a genuinely meritocratic profession
like much more than lots of other
professions
and one thing that's kept me in
recruitment
and we may come on later to why why
realm
um became a thing um versus why i
you know didn't ditch and go do the law
thing but i felt that actually
there was the possibility in this space
to really create something
really exciting and grow it a lot
quicker and be the leaders at it sooner
than you could in other walks of life
certainly than you could in law
so that that to me is a backdrop for me
saying that
it's a really exciting profession you
can achieve great things not just
financially but in terms of
where you can take yourself you know
there are graduates that have joined
realm
who within three four years have been
you know not just nominated but one one
awards external of the four walls of
realm
recognized as being the best at what
they do and
objectively probably aren't the best at
what they do you know they
they dominate the markets they sit in so
what you've got to be prepared for is
hard work
a steep learning curve because there's a
lot more to it i think than people let
on
um i would ignore what i
believe in my humble opinion to be
those ridiculous ote 70 to 100k
um adverts that you see because it's a
load of crap that's not gonna happen in
year one unless you
you know are you know the absolute
luckiest person in the world and you
kind of walk into a hot desk
so be prepared for a long game but by
long game i mean you know one or two
years of of grafting and maybe not
necessarily earning the big bucks
winning the awards
but then actually it can quickly take
off thereafter
yeah i love that and i think yeah i
think i would i would just average so
i'm excited to get
do this sort of graduate series is
because um i think
working in recruitment just equips you
with so many skills
like so many skills that you probably
didn't even expect
you might end up going into recruitment
thinking oh yeah i'm gonna i'm a good
sales person or i'm gonna get better at
sales but there's just so much more to
it
there's just so many more skills that
you'll hoover up and
it will just just for me when you do it
the right way and you have the right
mindset and you're in the right
environment it can just make you a
better all-rounded human
with so many skills that just benefit
all different parts of your life
absolutely do you know what i'd like to
build on that if i can
um yeah we have a core training program
at realm
and it's you know it really is just a
kind of minimum
that everybody needs to do in terms of
training and development and at the
moment it stands at about 36 hours of
training
and only a kind of tiny part of that two
three hours is around selling and
selling techniques
and of course we do follow-up we do
follow-up sessions on all of those call
sessions so you spend more than two or
three hours learning how to sell is my
point
but there's all that other stuff all
that other stuff
how to communicate better with people so
that you don't unknowingly cause
somebody else stress
how to remain resilient practical steps
to do that
how to organize yourself you're
absolutely right there's loads to it
that can benefit you above and beyond
just a day job of recruitment but you
can take into your personal life
yeah absolutely and obviously future
careers as well outside of
yeah 100 um so let's
let's sort of take this into dwayne
being the business owner then always
interested to hear a lot of people
talk about starting their own business
but never end up taking that first step
so what
what gave you the confidence to take
that first step and
and why i'm i have to be really truthful
about this i i was five years deep
into recruitment and the the last
two of those five years have been quite
good um yeah
in the grand scheme of things though i
still wasn't sure that recruitment was
for me
yeah and i felt like i'd finally made
peace
with with myself in terms of i've gone
into this and i've achieved something
maybe now is a good time to get out yeah
so
so i was actually thinking about finally
going and doing that whole barrister
thing right
yeah but then along came one of my
clients
and said to me we really like the work
you've been doing of us with us of late
and we were wondering whether you'd be
interested in setting a recruitment
business up with our backing
oh wow and i kind of thought well
it's not really what i set out to do but
why why would you dismiss that
opportunity they don't come along every
day especially
attract today yeah yeah they don't come
along every day
um and i thought you know what this
could be fun
this could be fun and actually it's that
thing again about recruitment being
meritocratic i thought to myself
because i was still pretty young i was
like 26 i was probably
well not probably i was mad that year
you've probably more
than i should have been and i thought do
you know what if i go and do this
this barrister law gig right i at best
might kind of become a barrister and be
a half good one in a few years time
but you know i'm not going to reach the
top of that profession for another 20 30
years
i thought you know what this recruitment
thing if i get it right
you know we could probably be best in
class within 10 years
and that really excited me so yeah
that that was how it was born nice see
so you got back to do it
pardon do you end up did you end up sort
of going down that route then did you
end up getting invested to start oh
sorry yeah yeah so yeah i accepted their
offer
i said yeah let's do it let's do it i
love that
i didn't know that so i'm excited to get
your experience on that because i think
that is something that people
sort of consider think about but again i
think it does
obviously the way that you described it
it seems pretty organic it's from people
in the industry but i think i don't know
if you've spoken to other
recruitment business owners about this
but um sometimes you can get quite a bad
rep on like
oh aren't these people just there to
sort of take my money or i'm not gonna
it's just like i don't know it doesn't
there's been some not great stories
around going down that path
yeah i do hear a lot of that um i'm
really fortunate
that my experience doesn't correlate
with that at all
um i've had nothing but
support and encouragement really along
the way yeah
don't get me wrong it's not been all
roses there were times in
the first couple of years especially
when it was
you know it was tense but that was
because the business wasn't performing
and you know what if a business isn't
performing the people that have backed
it
who are ultimately looking for a return
they're going to ask difficult questions
but to say to to go back to what you
said that some people see it that
investors are just there to take away
from you your money i
i don't see that in my situation i
actually carry myself really lucky you
count my blessings and go do you know
what realm wouldn't be here today
the business that it is did i not have
the backing
that i've got not just the financial
backing but the people that did it
because
the truth is our first couple of years
were really tough and difficult
and you know other investors
at that time might have gone do you know
what where i we've had enough of this
whereas the people that backed round i
guess they believed in me and what i was
saying and doing
they doubled down on their investment
and without that we wouldn't be in this
really exciting position we're in now
where we've got the foundations in place
and we're really fortunate to be able to
look five years ahead
and go do you know what that that
10-year goal we're on course to achieve
it
yeah i love that so very quickly then do
you mind
are you okay to share like how it works
don't have to go into like all the
details but like
people this is the stuff that people
want to know is it was it a straight
equity split
or i don't know like how how did how
does that look or does it change as you
hit certain goals
yeah yeah i can talk a little bit about
that i might not give specific figures
but i'm happy to kind of share the
overall yeah because i think that that
is
something that people are curious about
and how they do it so i think if you
didn't mind just
i guess just giving us a bit of a
picture of what that did what
what that actually looked like was you
just then put on would you then just
employ them on the salary and
i don't know how how did how did that
actually work so i think i probably got
the best of both worlds to be honest
i didn't have to put any money in yeah
you know the nature of the investment
was that
the two people that invested fronted the
money to run the company
um they gave me a split of the equity
yeah so i own part of the business
um but they also gave me the comfort of
a salary
yeah nice and on top of that um a
performance
bonus to incentivize me above and beyond
the equity that i had to grow it day to
day knowing that ultimately what what
our
combined plan is and what and sorry
wasn't is
is to keep growing it and if you grow a
business at great speed anyone will know
the amount of profitability in it is
limited for that time that you're
pushing the growth so
to compensate for the fact that
me owning equity yes that would mean i'd
get dividends but there might not be
huge dividends
for a while because we're reinvesting
the profit there was that
bonus there on the side that says well
regardless if you do x you'll get this
yeah i love that thank you for sharing
that so i'm really keen to talk about
the challenges that you had to work
through
because that's that's what this podcast
is all about so
but i think what will help is like just
paint the picture of where the business
is today
and then we'll talk about those first
couple of years and what you sort of i
guess learn
along that journey in hindsight now and
these things and then we'll talk about
sort of recent time so like where where
is the business today
so we've had a
rather crazy last 12 months as i know
lots of people
and businesses have um when
the pubs closed that's like the key date
i remember last year
when when the pubs closed and um we'd
just gone from seven to eight members of
staff
and then you know the week later we all
went into lockdown
we've now got 16 members of staff and
it'll be 17 as of july so we've more
than doubled head count over the last 12
months
the turnover looks like it's on course
for 1 million this year
which will be amazing for us because it
you know smashes
anything that we've that we've done
before and there'll be profitability
there
and we're on course for that that that
i don't want to say end goal but for
that in that sort of tenure picture that
i had in my mind when we started
that's that's now five years from now
we're on we're on course and trajectory
for that and that
what that looks like is probably about
50 members of staff
a turnover of three to four million
okay so talk to us about these first
couple of years then well obviously
it seems like obviously the great thing
about that
that and that ended up being the
investment partnership is obviously that
does de-risk it quite a bit right
it's absolutely taking that leap so
though i don't want to say it was more
comfortable but there was you're
stepping outside your comfort zone but
there was a comfortability there you
know
you could support your family or your
own personal circumstances etc so
obviously you said it was really
challenging and they stuck with you like
what
i guess what was really difficult let's
just talk about that and
maybe share some of the things that you
least expected that were really
challenging
i think what was difficult was was that
i'm
truthfully i wasn't yet at that stage in
my life equipped to run a business
i i didn't have a lot of the
skills understanding and experience that
i've now got
and that's maybe obvious because it's
maybe a bit chicken and egg but i think
there will be other people out there
in employed positions within recruitment
businesses now that would have had a lot
more
management team leadership general
leadership experience
than i'd had at that point so
in that first couple of years i was
having to
try to make fees myself as a recruiter
to get things moving
but because of this this goal this aim
of growing it quite quickly
we were very quick to hire people
graduates into the business
so i was also having to learn on the job
how to
train them how to coach them how to
manage them and get the best from them
and at the same time i was also having
to get to grips with the fact that
i had this this really exciting but
naive vision
of becoming best in class in 10 years
and
this this belief that i wanted to do
things maybe a bit different
to the way most of our competitors went
about recruiting
but i didn't really know what different
looked like i didn't really know what
that was
so i had to you know really go through a
trial and error process over that first
couple of years to kind of work out what
it was
um and all of those things combined
meant that the first two years when i
talk about them being difficult
i suppose what i mean was that it was
challenging
for me from a mental health standpoint
like i didn't necessarily realize it at
the time it's only when i came out the
other side but
it took its toll on me i was in a really
bad place um
in what sense the levels of anxiety
that i had to endure day to day were
awful i was bringing that anxiety into
my personal life
um it affected the way that
i kind of perceived myself it affected
the way that i went into
social activities with my friends it was
horrible it was just a real constant
niggle
um and it created a lot of self-doubt
which is not something i'd ever really
had before
i mentioned earlier on that um you know
i was quite an arrogant mid 20 something
that went that went and it was all of a
sudden self-doubt imposter syndrome
um but the other difficulty was that
this business wasn't wasn't making
business sense
it wasn't generating enough in the way
of revenue
for us to really call it a business and
how much do you do in your first
year and two if you don't mind sharing
uh i can't remember the exact specifics
but you know
frankly next to nothing like yeah one
probably just over
about 150 and maybe near double that in
year two
and how many of you were there um
between
three and four yeah and i know now with
hindsight that we got that whole thing
wrong
we just did it the wrong way we were too
eager to scale up
and remember what i said you know i was
trying to build whilst also trying to
teach these graduates
how to recruit whilst also you know
doing the other stuff i was just spread
too thinly
um it didn't work what we really should
have done was
build up more headroom first and then
grow give ourselves that foundation but
instead we try to do too much too soon
as it's happened as it happens it's not
worked out all that bad
because you know we're five years in now
and we've got
thanks to that hit that we took in those
first couple of years
we've got a solid foundations in the
businesses i could hope for
yeah but um yeah i don't know whether
i've gone off maybe on a bit of a
tangent there but yeah no no
no it's you're just talking about that
that generally so there's just so many
different when you're i'm sure when
you're thinking about it there's just so
many things that
come to you on like what the experience
was like and stuff so
i guess what we've taken from there is
like one of you had this investment so
obviously like right let's let's grow
this business but from what you've
shared it seems like
just end up doing that too quickly
because you didn't give yourself enough
space to
build relationships with maybe new
clients new business get enough business
in
through the door to then build a bit of
a platform that other people could
leverage you're then training other
people to
spread really thin like you said you're
doing a lot of firsts you
started to obviously doubt yourself and
you're now this business owner you've
got other people to care about you've
got obviously investors that you've got
to make sure that they're happy so
you're like oh my god
like am i actually as good as i thought
i was there's loads of things there
right
yeah so overwhelming yeah overwhelming
right so
i guess i know you were just touching on
it then but i guess for people listening
to this that
are thinking about taking that leap i
guess
so what i'm taking away from what you
said then is like a really dependent on
this
the nuance of the circumstance of how
you start your business if it's down the
investor room you do have more capital
or maybe you saved up
uh x amount of money to have like a six
month runway or whatever but
what what would you going back what
would you really focus on in those first
six to 12 months that you think would
have gave you
an even better platform to i guess to
reach sort of where you're at more
quickly now
this is maybe a slightly long-winded way
of answering that question but
when i reflect and look back the way i
see it is
we had this naive vision of doing things
different
and we didn't know what different was
and so
almost inadvertently whilst we were
scrambling around to be different we
ended up
just being exactly the same as all of
our competitors
and it's like why would anybody go to
those
new guys down the road for the same
service
that i can get with this really
established business that i know is
going to deliver the goods
does that does that make sense yeah you
did it you didn't really
now your usps will really work out yeah
yeah exactly
exactly and anything that we tried to
pedal as a usp on our website was as
hollow as you could get
didn't mean anything so
if i were to go back and do this whole
thing again before i even launched i
would work out
more clearly what it what it is that
this business is about why does this
business exist
how is it going to do what it does day
to day
and what does that mean for its
clients prospect candidates and i would
absolutely
nail that early doors so that
everything then would flow from that and
the other thing i would do differently
um this isn't a regret because actually
one of one of the guys
that joined us early doors he's still
with us he's brilliant
he's award-winning so it's worked out
really well
but you know if i'm being truthful if i
did the whole thing again
i wouldn't hire as quickly i would i
would focus on
just me using that you know that
proposition
building things up establishing a name
for us in the market
getting some really solid clients
that we're going to do repeat business
with again and again and again
and build up a bit of headroom and then
inject inject stuff
you know nice just on that just really
practical and i know again there's
nuances but
thinking back that headroom would you
want that to look like i don't know
maybe like
obviously there's a just something i
guess like financials would you be
looking at like i don't know
like a six six month runway of not
worrying at all about this new person
having to build or bring in revenue or
are you talking more about
a pla i guess it's both but i don't know
what what would you be aiming for out of
interest
you know i wouldn't be able to put a
figure on that because it will really
depend on the specific situation that
you're in
suffice to say the situation we were in
meant that the business was losing
not just losing money but losing money
quite drastically
you know quite a junk month on month um
and that obviously wasn't good so
i think the answer to that is really
based on what you can afford
or what your investors can afford yeah
fair enough
any on the mental health piece and thank
you for
sharing um how you felt during that
because i think
again still plenty of work to get more
people talking about but any sort of
coping mechanisms that i guess you still
utilize now that
helps keep that in check or have helps
you have better
sort of more good days and bad days sort
of looking back was there anything that
did
help during that period that you think
actually really helped you
work through that talking
yeah and sharing um i've
i've had counselling and i think it's
brilliant it's really
really brilliant how has that actually
helped you like how was that
sort of it's that manifest
it's quite hard to articulate because
it's not as if you
you go in and have these sessions and
go away at the end with these really
practical bits of advice on what to do
it's almost that just through the
process of going through counseling
you end up with a lot more just clarity
and a clearer mind so that really helped
um i think practically things that
i do now that that help me
personally well there's there's a
there's an idea that there you've got
five fibers of resilience
this is something i'm borrowing from a
talk that i went to the back end of last
year you've got
mental emotional physical social
and spiritual so
the idea is the stronger those five
fibers of resilience
the more resilient you become and the
more resilient you are i think you know
that goes hand in hand with mental
health
so i try to
develop knowledge um
i one thing that we encourage at realm
is self-development we've got loads of
things in place that do that but i try
to live and breathe that myself
so try to do a lot to kind of develop
myself in that sense
emotional resilience i think that's
around stretching yourself so at realm
we talk not so much about getting
outside of your comfort zone but growing
your comfort zone
so doing something that develops you
personally
physical resilience well that's that's
the easy one to understand
but maybe more difficult one to stick to
but you know
exercise um social resilience i think
that's about
sharing sharing positivity in love with
others looking after others i think
that's very rewarding
uh and i think the strongest one of all
is the spiritual one and by spiritual i
don't necessarily mean
religion or or some sort of you know
voodoo or witchcraft but rather a sense
of purpose
a goal something that drives you and
and again i'm going to refer to the talk
that i went to the back end of last year
that really
helped crystallize all of this for me
one practical tip that i got given then
was to have have goals that stretch you
goals that are not
so obviously attainable that you know
you know you're gonna do that thing
but things that are maybe a little bit
dicey like it's push and go
if not slightly unrealistic write them
down
and stick them in front of you right and
and the idea is that if they're in front
of you all the time
you're unconscious without you knowing
it is taking that information in
and he's processing it and he's getting
creative and trying to do something with
it
but also if you're having a crap day you
can just look down at it
and remind yourself this is this is why
i'm doing this
and um that helps a lot yeah
love that thanks for sharing that so
let's let's
start unpacking what you i guess
some of the things that have really
helped you get to where you are now then
and the things that
have really started um working then so
always interesting
it's a really popular question i get
from other business owners
what along the way or um things that
sort of you live by now what um
tools have you invested in as a business
that's really helped you think
as you started growing and building this
this platform as a business
any tools that you live by so practical
tools you mean like linkedin recruiter
for example
yeah just just people always message me
like i'd love to know what pieces of
tech
other businesses have invested in that
they actually use and really rate or
really value because there's
also loads of tools out there but
yeah um honestly we're maybe slightly
tech averse at realm
first so i i think we have the things
that you have to have
a crm system another multi-poster
linkedin recruiter licenses
but based on some bad experiences with
various pieces of tech early on so we
were really
early adopters of like a video um
interview piece of kit
where we had that one started and back
in 2015 that was pretty novel
didn't really work for us um we had a
chat about
chat bot on our website at one point
didn't really work for us
we had this artificially intelligent
text message system
didn't really work for us so
i'm afraid i've not got much to say that
that's
in the way of kind of practical
takeaways um other than that we are
actually
just in the process now of trialing um
intro an interview oh nice so
i firmly believe that video has
definitely got a place in recruitment
now
and um i think it's time that we at rome
had another look at that whether or not
we adopted yet or not i don't know
um but we try we try not to rely
on tech we try to rely more on us
yeah fair enough so let's just get
get into some practical things so i'd
say the other really popular area that
recruiters always
uh want to learn listen um about is
over the last we can keep it in the last
12 to uh
18 months like what as a business as
you've grown in that period like what
has been
sort of the most successful way for you
and your team to win business
out of interest okay um business right
well
we our mission statement right at realm
is
we believe in treating lawyers like
people not candidates
and we believe in treating law firms
like valued partners
not just transactional customers okay
so in terms of winning business that's
the starting point for us
treat both your existing clients and
your prospective clients
like valued partners and not just a
transactional customer that you're
hoping to get a fee off
and in practice what does that look like
well we try to
add value in whatever way we can so
whether that's sending them a piece of
research that we've run as a business
that we know is going to have data in
that's going to benefit them
whether it's reaching out to them to
just offer them
insight on what's going on in the market
you know i don't want to give too many
of our secrets away
um so maybe won't say any more but just
add value
in whatever way you can go out of your
way to help them is another way i
suppose to put that
the second thing is i think we've got a
pretty clear idea of what our
proposition is
so this is the second time i'm
referencing this and it's the thing that
i said i wish i'd
nailed down and bolted on the walls of
our office a lot sooner
but we understand what our why is what's
driving us and it's that mission
statement
we understand how it is that we do our
job so that's a you know we've got
we pride ourselves around having a
refreshing refreshing
values driven approach and we know what
our values are we know what they mean
and we emphasize those to clients and
ultimately we know how those things
combined
help and benefit our clients and we
emphasize that we emphasize that
we save you time we save you money
we help you to make money so all of that
combined with
the way we're set up as a business and
the way we're set up as a business
is a huge part i think of our success so
i'll explain that
we are ultra niche at realm so
many of the listeners to this might
think legal is quite specialist in
itself
but we take that to the empty degree
each recruiter in our team
only recruits one or in some cases two
types of lawyer and that's it
and not only that but they are confined
to a relatively small geographical area
so by playing
a long game on the candidate front there
by not just
jumping headfirst and trying to get
candidates for jobs
but rather knowing that actually i've
only got this finite pool of potential
candidates
so rather than just trying to pick from
them and place them in jobs quickly
instead i'm just going to focus on
building relationships with these people
and being the person that they
automatically think of
when they think of moving jobs all of
that combined
it kind of makes our life relatively
easy when it comes to working
trying to work to a new business because
in the areas that the legal areas that
we cover
we've just got such good mature talent
pools and
on top of that i think we know
the value in adding value to clients and
prospects to show them what we're not
just trying to
look for a quick fee and we also on top
of that you know we know the why the how
and the what so we can articulate what
it is that we do for them and how that
adds value
um that's slightly long-winded answer
and i don't know how much of that
people can extract and practically do
themselves but
yeah i think that that's been the key
for us in winning new business and
retaining the clients we've got
certainly the last three years it just
seemed it just seems like you just
matured as a business
like these are all that's what it sounds
like really
it's like you've got systems and
processes and we're all on the same
thing whereas
i think a business like and this is
gonna be my next question because a
really common question i get as well is
like
obviously a large chunk of the
recruitment industry is
sort of um as a business size where you
was under that sort of 10
head count and i think sometimes the
things that you're mentioning can also
can be perceived as things that you
would do when you're bigger or larger or
when
we're over here we'll do that but well
it seems like you've really done
the legwork and all of that so then
actually when you do grow when you do
add people and as we are doing it then
we're all cl it's all really clear
basically i think sometimes that's what
can lack and that was going to be my
next question really like
um it was there's two things i think
um obviously one was going to be okay so
for people listening to this that do
have a business
where you was so under 10 heads what
advice would you give them to sort of
get to that next level i know you're
still on that journey but i guess things
that have helped you might be the things
you just mentioned
and then the other thing which i think
is sort of core to that is that
which people always want to know is like
how have you developed leaders
how have you got obviously i know you
shared with me obviously and i hope you
don't mind me sharing them so you're due
to have your first child soon so
obviously you're going to be out the
business so i'm sure this is something
you've done like how you develop leaders
and how have you got them on the bus
you know because that's going to be
important as you grow this so i know a
few things there but
do you know what and that that's that's
a tough one
because as you said i'm i'm still kind
of going through that journey like you
know
i i can't sit here and say to you
we've done it you know we're there
because we're absolutely not we've got
miles to go
um not to say that i'm not proud of
where we are i am but we've still got
miles to go and i think because we're
still going through that process
i haven't yet got that benefit of
hindsight to be able to reflect back
and go those were the things that really
made the difference
but i'll try and have a go at answering
it anyway
um good systems and processes i think
are really important
i know that they're not for everybody um
and i know that you know when we've
hired people that have worked in other
recruitment businesses
they've maybe found some of the things
that we insist
upon a little bit arduous or tiresome
and i think we've got maybe as a
business some way to go in
getting better at explaining the
benefits of why these things exist
to newer team members but they do help
they really do they they make sure that
whatever it is that's got
you to the point of being 10 members of
staff because by the way i don't think
you get to 10 members of staff without
having a viable business there
and loyal clients and all the rest of it
so whatever it is that's got you
got you to that point they help ensure
that you don't lose the essence of that
almost you capture it and then it's
easier to replicate
um the
the other thing i suppose is
a clear structure for how you're going
to grow
so where you're going to put people how
that's going to benefit those that are
already there
um something that i'm
proud of at realm is that we really see
the value in
not just having a load of recruiters but
also in having support staff
so in a team of 16 take me out leaves 15
we've got one two three four five
six six members of support staff and
nine recruiters
i don't think that's that sort of ratio
is very normal in recruitment
and what do they do sorry is that one
sharing so
we've two people that sit within kind of
the admin side of the business and hr
and then four that sit within marketing
and
and certainly in in the early years of
running realm i was going to
talk after talk after talk you know
desperately trying to find
the recipe to get things moving and i
quite often heard this thing about how
you know recruitment to some extent
isn't just sales but it's just as much
marketing
and um so i tried i try to kind of take
that on board and do something with it
and hence why we have a marketing team
of four now
um because yeah so much of what we do
and underpins
the success that we're currently having
stems from the work of that marketing
team
so i guess practical bit of advice is
think about the bigger picture in the
team structure don't just throw a load
of recruiters at it actually having more
support staff
might actually enable the recruiters
you've got to believe in more
and give you even more solid a base
of which to continue growing i love that
as for the leader part um i'm grappling
with this at the moment i've got
i've got a group of people that i work
with
who i trust a lot and i've known for a
long while
and i see them as leaders
and i think the challenge that i'm faced
with is
helping them to see themselves as
leaders and understand
how that changes sort of the dynamic as
to wait the way they
act and behave day-to-day and
again i'm just just being honest and
saying that you know i've not mastered
that yet it's an ongoing
thing and what i've done so far
well i think one thing we're relatively
good at
or rather i'm relatively good at is is
giving feedback and
ensuring that it's not just a you know
let's have a chat now and i'll see you
in 12 months time for your next
appraisal but
more structured one-to-one system
monthly an appraisal system that's more
regular
and we've got a really transparent
progression policy
that says in order to move up the ranks
these are the things you need to do and
by the way there's nine criteria and
only one of them relates to billings
there's all this other stuff so i guess
what i'm trying to say is
there's a in my mind at least there's an
ongoing dialogue with people
around the areas of development and the
things they need to do
to move up and i think that combined
with
you know me starting now to do practical
things and have conversations with them
about them awakening
to the idea that the leaders that's the
strategy thus far
yeah no thank you for sharing that and
then i guess as we come to the end here
always obviously a challenge for growing
businesses is hiring for their own
business
have you got any better have you got any
better at that
do you know what that implies that i was
once not great here and you know what
you'd be right like that yes
i made some shocking decisions on that
front um yeah i guess just
i get the it's just two two-part
questions one have you got any better at
it and two
the other thing that i think whenever i
have these conversations
is like people um
have had to get better at i guess just
just noticing and understanding what
their hiring triggers are for their
business
you know rather than i don't know just
always i guess seeing people go yeah
they
sound good let's get them in i don't
know so that that was the other part i
was going to say but
how how has that journey been
yes we've got better at it as a business
and
more through the the efforts
of my colleague becky who's our office
manager and oversees
the hr functions within the business
she's put something in place that is
just a lot more structured
and more closely aligned
with what's important to us at realm
so with a three-stage process you know
the first is just a 15-minute matter
with me where
i get to sense check whether this person
seems to be on the face of it worth
moving forward and they get to sense
check where their eyes seem to be
somebody that they want to work with
then we've a second stage which is
a longer more traditional interview i
suppose that looks a technical aptitude
and then a third stage that looks at
cultural
fit now i think what we've got
better at is kind of understanding that
as much as we've got
values at realm and whoever we hire
and they have to align with those that
actually it's not a one-size-fits-all
approach
you know i don't think having clones
works you need
different people from different
backgrounds with different viewpoints
i think that's another thing that's
actually helped us along
our kind of way the last five years
um so yeah not not not being
too rigid in saying that people have to
look
and sound a certain way but but
that said they do have to align with
these values these sets of this set of
non-negotiables that's really important
to us
so yeah to answer the question shortly
we have got better reddit
uh the second part um
again to be honest still not there with
that one it has been a very
very much uh ad hoc opportunistic
approach
to growing the business in recent years
that that is now coming to a stop
because we're at a point now where
we can't push and grow any further
without first
taking a step back putting some more
structure in place and looking at
the um whether we've got the right
ratios of support staff and kind of what
what our sub team structure looks like
and reporting lines
all that kind of stuff so once we've
done that then we are going to
move forward have a more structured way
of recruiting and look to do kind of
intakes where we have multiple people on
board at
once rather than just people all over
the shop i think
that is a more productive way of doing
it from our perspective
but it's also probably a better
experience to somebody starting a new
business
because they've got peers that are
joining at the same time it kind of
softens the landing into the team
yeah nice and then look before we
finish and ask you the sort of final
couple of questions
how obviously during this period it
seems like there's been a lot more
positives but how uh
how's your mental health been in this
period
pretty good i'm fortunate that i can say
that
because as i've got older
i think i've become more self-aware and
can i'm better now at recognizing
when maybe i'm not feeling great and so
i can do something about it whereas when
i was
26 that's how old i was when i launched
realm i was
nowhere near as self-aware and was
very naive so is that just common veins
do you think or
is it because of the work you've done on
self-development or i don't know
what uh i think a combination of
those things yeah the combination of
those things definitely
and um yeah the counselling helped too
so yeah i i can't i can't myself really
lucky actually that
this last 12 months i know has been
incredibly incredibly difficult
for a lot of people um i'm really
fortunate that
you know i've landed okay and how are
you feeling about
adding uh another human in your life
being a family i did a post about this
other day because uh
i guess um the context is
when not whenever i've interviewed women
on this podcast and we sort of talk
about
why what are some of the reasons behind
a lack of women and sort of senior
leadership positions and you may see
this in your sector
um obviously one of the factors that
us guys don't have don't think about as
much doesn't mean that we don't sort of
deem it as important is this little
crossroads of like right do i wanna
start a family or am i gonna put
everything into my career can i have
both etc
so you've got this business now you've
got a lot of people to
support so how are you how are you
feeling about that
do you know what actually the the one
thing that maybe i have had a
tinge of anxiety about over the last
eight or nine months uh has not been
becoming
a father because i cannot wait i'm so
excited
um i love that to welcome our baby girl
but rather whether i'm going to have
the right balance between life and work
when she arrives because this is
something that
i try to put a huge emphasis on within
the business
i mean our whole vision is about
becoming the leaders in our space but
whilst recognizing that
you know when it comes to life work
balance it's life that's the more
important of the two right
um and because of how fast we've grown
as a business
the structures and the support isn't
quite there yet or hasn't been there yet
for me to feel confident that um
basically i'm going to be
you know a good dad in that i'm going to
be home and around enough so that's a
work in progress
um but yeah i'm just so excited i can't
wait
yeah i love that so before i ask you the
final question then what
i guess for anyone listen to this that
could be a
maybe aspiring business owner and
what advice would you have for them then
but the journey that you're on if i'm
listening to this and i'm thinking about
starting my own recruitment business
someday
what would you communicate to me
i could spend a lot of time and think
very carefully
about all sorts of bits of practical
advice that i would give
but actually the thing that
i would say above all else is just give
it a go
you only get one you only get one go at
life right so
um there's a there's a book that we've
read at our book club at work
sorry a shameless plug there but it's
okay um
by a lady called elizabeth day and um
that's called was it fail first or
something what is that theology
philosophy theology it's all about why
it's okay to fail
and there's a quote go something like um
the minute you let go of your fear of
failure
you score more yeah i love that i've got
that i should post it on my
computer in front of me and says you can
do this for your equals growth because i
i've definitely struggled with that in
when i've been in my own sort of
business
journey it's definitely a third piece it
is always the fear and exactly so as
the point is i could try to give you
loads of practical advice and you could
go around and ask a load of other
business owners for practical advice
but ultimately you know you just got to
crack on and do it you got to do it your
way
and don't let the fear of failure stop
it stop you give it a go take that first
step
yeah well um so what final question then
what what's the ultimate goal for
the realm what's ultimate goal for your
recruitment career
so i've just alluded to it there it's
it's our vision
statement as a business we want to
become the leading legal recruitment
consultancy
in the uk but doing that whilst
putting you know life above work um so
where i see us in five years time is
probably a head count of about 50 staff
members
and um i want us to be
in the sunday times top 10 list for best
small companies to work for
that's that that's how i'll know that
i've achieved what i set out to achieve
yeah building something up that's
financially viable and successful
but where people actually like to come
and work
yeah well i'm excited to see that
unravel from afar thanks so much for
being on the podcast
thank you for having me good luck with
fatherhood obviously
stay in touch but um yeah thanks a lot
for coming on and being really
open and honest and um really excited to
share this with everyone so thank you
very welcome
cheers